but then let's let's try something else
because we're doing funny look who's
back
oh well yeah he's back he was gone for a
while and his wife actually did die
recently
um efrog's wife died they had they
actually had like a viking funeral for
her
seriously like the videos are online um
and uh he's back he came out of hiding
it's our good friend e frog he's got
something for you all right youtubers
i got a little song for you he's got a
song
his own parodies wrote it myself this
morning get ready
all right here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is better than anything crowder's
ever done this is better than crowder
of your power
[Music]
oh big show's off to a weird start at
aew i don't know why
[Music]
confirmed
what
[Laughter]
sean in the chat says metallica really
don't even try anymore
now if joe biden wanted to secure
my vote in the next election would like
he would stay alive
but uh if if joe biden wanted to win me
over he would just hire e-frog and come
out to this oh [ __ ] it'd be amazing
like you know what man this is all right
fighting's pretty cool
biden's motorcade comes out with him
playing the guitar like the dude in the
new mad max fury road thing
strapped to the front of the car fire
shooting out
by the way that mad max movie was so bad
for your road yeah
oh my god hey let's make a mad max movie
where mad max doesn't do anything the
whole time that was good i like
he did nothing the whole movie that was
good
[Music]
a lot of james hadfield uh influence
here yeah he's a big metallica guy
australian
worships satan joe biden
first fake president
the
[Music]
will
[Music]
oh
all right
silver lining here okay in his defense
i'm just playing devil's navigation a
did say the a he said it with the a he
did say with the a
it's it's okay it's fine no mike
no
he just i mean it went in and i i felt
where it was going but it was too late
for any of us to stop it
let's hear it again we'll destroy
america
joe biden is obama's [ __ ]
fake news distributor
[Music]
is
[Music]
sick guitar riff here comes the miller
highlight
alaska highlights oh he's weed man oh
[ __ ] dude
[Music]
i hope you like it f joe biden no no no
my friend i love it i [ __ ]
love it gotta be honest the beard's a
good look for him
yeah i know it works you gotta keep the
beard it works for him it really does
eat frog if you see this clip or you're
watching this
keep the beard buddy
good for him wow glad he's doing all
right
looks like he's handling his wife's
death really well well you know
i think yeah i mean he is technically
it's like unironically i agree with that
because
i mean he's always been nuts
at least here he's just jamming
good for him gotti e frog's the man
yeah uh at least he's better than earl
people saying yeah e-frog's another one
that i
i can't can't hate efrock he's
too much fun like the fact that he let
us goof on him when he came on here and
he can kind of take a
he can kind of take a [ __ ] beating is
why i like efrog like he frog at least
is self-aware and has a sense of humor
about himself
so it's like that's a very disarming
thing like you can't hate a person who's
like yeah you goof on me whatever it's
like
all right you're cool because remember
we got we had him on that one time
and we were gonna shred him for being a
dork but he was actually funny he
actually made us laugh
oh yeah like okay you know what you're
actually pretty cool he's actually a
pretty cool dude he's solving self-aware
[ __ ]